[Musique]
bonsoir à tous vous regardez le 7 8 et
les invités nous sommes le mercredi 28
septembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle émission au programme de
trois invités aujourd'hui nous recevons
aujourd'hui en plateau à julien le cam
secrétaire régional adjoint du syndicat
alliance police nationale fermetures de
commissariats événements publics annuler
ni grand il fera le point avec nous en
plateau fin et le festival orphée a
débuté hier dans les yvelines pour lui
en parler les charlottes earth président
du festival il reviendra avec nous sur
les différentes manifestations qui se
dérouleront jusqu'au interne d'octobre
et du sport enfin pour finir nous
reviendrons sur la course du vendée
globe avec le skipper yvelinois éric
bellion versailles et nous parlera de sa
première participation à cette aventure
avec son bateau comme un seul homme et
de nombreux événements publics sont
annulées dans les yvelines le territoire
s'attend à recevoir des migrants d'ici
peu ton à côté de cela des commissariats
ferme quelle est la situation pour les
policiers nous en parlerons ce soir avec
julien le cam secrétaire à la régional
adjoint du syndicat alliance police
bonsoir à vous bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation lors tout
d'abord nous en avons beaucoup parlé ces
derniers temps les événements publics
annulé est ce que justement cela
concerne la police forcément est ce
qu'on vous demande plus de travail que
c'est difficile voilà de sécuriser ces
événements comme les brocantes comme les
grands braderie qui ont vu dans les
yvelines effectivement les la
sécurisation d'événements et de plus en
plus
demandé par les élus les renforts sont
nécessaires en termes de polices mais ça
n'a pas vraiment d'incidence sur le
déroulement de l'événement et
nombre d'annulations on voit que paris
versailles de dimanche s'est déroulée
dans de très bonnes conditions les
services d'ordre était assurée voilà un
service dans effectivement conséquent
mais il n'y a pas d'incidence en termes
d' annulation en tout cas sur les
secteurs police actuellement les maires
notamment le maire du chesnay proche de
chez nous en place une réserve civile de
sécurité civile voilà les nerfs des
sites de demande aux citoyens de les
aider pour assurer la sécurité quel
message ça donne pour l'appeler s'il n'y
a pas assez de policiers donc il faut
faire appel à des citoyens alors le
maire du chesnay effectivement c'est
quelqu'un qui a perdu son bureau de
police il ya environ deux ou trois ans
le bureau de police a été fermé pour des
problèmes d'effectif je peux comprendre
un mois il a aussi également une police
municipale
au-delà de ça et les effectifs
versailles et interviennent sur le
chesnay je ne pense pas que ce soit
nécessaire ce genre de deux groupes si
vous voulez cette formation de deux
groupes donc si on résume les événements
publics y sont annulés pour faute de
sécurité ça c'est pas du un problème
d'effectif mais via ce lien on a des
problèmes d'effectifs sur le département
ça on voit très bien il ya des
fermetures de commissariats de prévu
donc effectivement on est en manque
d'effectif sur le département les
collègues participent et sécurisé le
plus grand nombre d'événements possibles
malheureusement
ben on voit il ya peut-être eu certaines
annulations mais en tout cas voilà pas
dû forcément aux effectifs de la police
n'est pas alarmante selon vous non non
non pas du tout je voudrais revenir
également sur un problème d'effectif de
commissariats récemment le le comme ça
devait les il va fermer bientôt vous
êtes au courant justement de ça est ce
que vous nous en dire un peu plus
comment ça s'explique cité c'était
inévitable depuis la restructuration des
services sur le 78 et la perte de
presque 300 effectifs sur le département
une dizaine d'années ça a eu un impact
considérable sur l'organisation des
services et il ya des services qui n'ont
qui ne peuvent plus tourner comme le
commissariat de vélizy de la celle saint
cloud c'est des petites structures qui
par manque d'effectifs vont ferme et
vont fermer est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
commissariats qui sont concernés dans
les yvelines où sur 50 ans alors le
directeur nous a annoncé la fermeture de
petites structures comme bombe à vélizy
il faut s'inquiéter à mon avis pour le
commissariat de la celle saint cloud les
petites structures comme marly-le-roi et
c'est effectivement on craint par manque
d'effectif que ces structures là soient
fermés parce qu'il s'est récemment à
passer à marier le roi s'est calmée en
béton vraiment inquiétant que un
commissariat proche ferme alors qu'il ya
eu des tirs dans un dans un magasin très
vaguement effectivement nous on tire la
sonnette d'alarmé alliance police
nationale tire la sonnette d'alarmé
réclament des effectifs sur le
département depuis des années et le
constat est le même à chaque mouvement à
la rentrée on est en négatif à chaque
fois il ya plus de départs que
d'arrivées effectivement
on arrive à des situations
voilà inquiétante comme les fermetures
de commissariats un dernier point voilà
sujet auquel je voudrais vous faire
réagir le préfet l'a décidé vendredi
dernier cela a été annoncé
officiellement 400 migrants vont arriver
dans les élites doivent être accueillis
cette voie là c'était une annonce qui a
fait peur à la population aux maires qui
sont concernés notamment du doigt
parivar concours et à louveciennes vous
avez été informé justement de sart est
ce que vous vous adonnez peut-être des
directives déjà ce progrès aucune nous
on n'a pas été informée syndicats
policiers nous n'avons pas été informés
on l'a appris par la presse donc
effectivement il ya une forme
d'inquiétude parce que bas comme on
l'évoquait à ce manque d'effectif bon
deux en même temps l'arrivée de migrants
s'apparente pas forcément à une
augmentation de la délinquance on l'a vu
sur versailles avec l'arrivée d'une
soixantaine de migrants on n'a pas
constaté une housse des faits de
délinquance donc par contre c'est vrai
que nous on s'inquiète parce que avec la
fermeture du bureau de police du chesnay
le commissariat dieu de la celle saint
cloud qui en manque d'effectif et qui ne
tourne quasiment pu effectivement on
s'inquiète on souhaite avoir des
renforts il faudrait que le préfet fasse
des demandes de renforts d'effectifs de
police s'il faut des renforts en tête
pour accueillir ces gens pour voilà pour
laquelle le moment vous avez besoin
d'effectifs dès le départ oui là
actuellement il ya des manifestations
sur versailles sur loup sienne
cdc des manifestations qu'il faut
encadrer il faut sécuriser ces
manifestations là ça nécessite beaucoup
d'effectifs qui sont déjà pris eux sur
des missions antiterroristes sur des
missions de police secours donc voyez
dès le départ même même sans qu'il soit
là ce sacre est déjà un problème de
sécurité publique ring par les
manifestations donc nous on s'inquiète
parce qu'on a besoin d'effectifs ce sera
le mot de la fin merci juin le week end
est revenue en plateau et d'avoir
accepté de venir sur cette émission
merci beaucoup passent maintenant tout
autre sujet la culture le festival
orphée a débuté hier dans les yvelines
un festival de théâtre avec de la danse
de la musique des contes mais aussi des
conférences autour du handicap car la
plupart des intervenants sont en
situation de handicap pour nous en
parler c'est richard leteurtre le
président du festival qui a accepté
parlez à mélanie potier regarder
27 septembre c'est l'inauguration du
festival orphée en yvelines je dis ça
parce que la particularité peut-être un
c'est que il y à deux festivals qui se
sont réunis et ça c'est quand même une
chose très importante parce que orphée
existe depuis 2004 et le festival viva
la vida existe depuis 2012 et on a
décidé de se réunir ensemble on est
quand même des départements voisins avec
la même ligne artiste il est même
motivation juste pour cette fois
tu voi dans l'ombre tu sentiras bien
[Musique]
festival art et handicap comme c'est
écrit sur la fiche festival art et
handicap qui regroupe à peu près toutes
les sortes de handicaps que l'on peut
trouver avec la particularité que ces
personnes en situation de handicap sont
les comédiens les danseurs les artistes
que l'on verra sur les plateaux de
théâtre des yvelines du val d'oise près
de paris bien sûr majoritairement on
privilégie les spectacles où il ya des
personnes en situation de handicap mais
on peut aussi avoir des spectacles y en
a quelques-uns pas beaucoup bien sûr
parce qu'il faut garder cette proportion
mais on a par exemple deux spectacles de
deux monologues de femmes eu un qui va
se dérouler d'ailleurs ici c'est un peu
le c'est un peu le clin d'oeil puisqu'on
est dans un lieu du handicap donc on va
présenter un spectacle une personne
valide mais c'est juste parce que
c'était un bon spectacle j'avais vu
avignon
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi être bipolaire
sans corset
sur le visage
c'est qu'il vous
parce si on regarde derrière les grands
murs à qui dit vous sera par la folie
tous les handicaps peuvent être présents
et tous les handicaps peuvent être à un
moment donné sur un plateau parce que ce
sont aussi des artistes c'est quelque
chose qu'on comprend très bien dans le
milieu de la peinture on parle même d'
art brut on dit pas que frida kahlo par
exemple était quelqu'un qui était en
fauteuil et pourtant c'était quelqu'un
en fauteuil donc à ce niveau là puisque
ce n'est pas visible et que leur art et
quelques à cacher en tout cas enfin la
personne est caché derrière son marron
l'admets mais sur les plateaux de
théâtre c'est plus difficile c'est vrai
que des danseurs en fauteuil des
danseurs avec une jambe en moins un bras
en moins ça ça peut ça peut interpeller
tenez l'autre jour j'étais devant la
porte de mon immeuble
bon visiblement on avait changé le code
et là j'entends
hausse michael
chabon
à
temps perdu les clés du fort
oui j'habite en banlieue
de la voile à présent vous le savez nous
en avons déjà parlé trois skippers
illinois participe au vendée globe l'un
d'eux est originaire de versailles c'est
eric bellon le navigateur participera
pour la première fois autour du monde
sans escale et sans assistance le 6
novembre prochain avec son bateau comme
un seul homme michael almy d'euros la
rencontrer pour nous regarder
moi je me sens bizarrement super serein
et bizarrement parce que je m'y
attendais pas du tout je pensais que
plus les jours à les approcher avant le
départ là il ya cinquante trois jours
plus j'allais être stressé et c est en
fait c'est l'effet inverse qui arrive
plus la date approche plus je suis
serein l'année dernière j'étais assez
tendu et encore quelques mois j'étais
assez tendu et puis depuis que j'ai fait
ma qualification depuis qu'en fait j'ai
su un peu comment naviguer en solitaire
ce bateau ce que je savais pas j'avais
jamais fait solitaire avant le bain
depuis que j'ai fait cette
expérimentation là ça va beaucoup mieux
je me sens bien les questions vos
objectifs sur ce vendée globe s'est
terminé la course avant tout
l'eau a déjà le premier objectif c'est
d'être au départ et même si c'est dans
53 jours il peut arriver des tas de
choses donc c'est d'être au départ et
c'est déjà c'est déjà une aventure
extraordinaire d'être au départ parce
qu'il ya déjà deux ans de travail pour
trois ans donc c'est assez énorme et
après l'objectif pendant la course et
c'est clair que c'est de finir
en fait nos objectifs
c'est vraiment à l'arrivée me regarder
dans la glace et de me dire
tu as bien assurer ta fête a fait une
belle course tu as donné tout ce que tu
avais
tu es allé au bout de toi même tu es tu
allé là où tu pensais pas aller et
est un rendu les gens heureux est
apporté ton message de plus loin
possible ça voilà c'est l'objectif on
n'a pas d'autre en fait c'est vraiment
mythique île course comme le vendée
globe c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
mythiques pour un marin le vendée globe
moi je me suis jamais quand j'étais plus
jeune je me suis jamais projeté en
disant tiens un jour jusqu'à le vendée
globe c'était impossible c'était comme
si que tu fais du football étudie un
jour je fais la coupe du monde de foot
c'est juste ce n'était pas ce n'était
pas atteignable et puis un jour je me
suis dit si c'est en fait c'est
atteignable et si chaud si je m'en donne
les moyens si je travaille très dur ça
va être atteignable mais ouais c'est
mythique il ya derrière de crocus et
ce qui est plus difficile c'est
le plus engageants c'est le saut dans
l'inconnu le plus incroyable parce que
jour du départ qui partent affronter les
océans de la planète tout seul sur un
bateau qui est grand qui est compliqué
donc ouais c'est un vrai saut dans
l'inconnu qui est fabuleux il y avait
sept skipper les meilleurs du monde la
compétition l'a vraiment un scrutin
cette année il ya les meilleurs marins
du monde il ya un plateau exceptionnel
on est une petite trentaine
et des bateaux neufs il ya des courses
dans la course
ça n'a pas arrêté de se croiser ça va
être super intéressant ça va être ouais
ça va être passionnant vous êtes 3
illinois s'abonner à prendre le départ
comment l'expliquez vous et qui
authentifie une loi qui crée le départ
d'une compétition aussi mythique le
vendée globe bah je crois que c'est la
mère a pas de frontières et on n'a pas
besoin d'être né
près de la mer pour pour rêver à la mer
moi quand j'étais petit à versailles
j'étais sous la couette avec les
bouquins de mer je rêvais de mer et j'ai
découvert la mer à l'adolescence et
depuis j'ai pas lâché et je crois qu'on
est beaucoup dans mon cas j'ai pas du
tout un cas isolé il ya beaucoup de
divine oies qui pensent qu'ils pensent à
la mer qui rêvent de la mer et qu'il
était profite justement des vacances
pour aller naviguer et surtout moi
j'aimerais leur dire mais allez-y à fond
le rêve est atteignable et si vous avez
vraiment envie de vivre cette passion la
ddt allez-y c'est ce extraordinaire au
départ du vendée globe ce sera le 6
novembre prochain c'est à présent la fin
du set 8es les invités jour merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée
[Musique]